daily wire report says old school
liberal investigative journalist matt
taibi told ben shapiro on this week's
episode of sunday special that he lost
friends for merely reviewing
matt walsh in the daily wires
groundbreaking documentary what is a
woman we have a little bit of that clip
from the sunday special the whole
conversation is well worth watching by
the way you can go to uh ben's youtube
page and
see the whole thing but here's that part
of the discussion go ahead
i had kind of tried to stay away from
the issue i
you know it's it's complicated i i try
to avoid issues that i don't know a
whole lot about
but i had i had done a couple of stories
that touched on this basically from the
speech angle
and i'd had a really unusual experience
i mean i've been a reporter for
30 years now and it's always the same
method you call around a whole bunch of
people you ask them all what they think
and then at the end you kind of
aggregate all the opinions and figure
out where the story is but with the
trans issue what i found is i would call
some people and they would talk to me
and then there'd be this other group of
people who would be furious that you
even called uh would refuse to have any
kind of discussion would call you a
transphobe for even asking certain kinds
of questions and this is before you even
have a point of view on the subject
uh so i was you know i thought that was
odd um and then i had done an interview
with a woman named karadanski who is a
feminist a gender critical feminist
and
i it's not that i purposely shelved it i
just didn't want to deal with the
blowback that i knew was going to come i
i kept telling myself it wasn't the
right time
so i i felt guiltier and guiltier about
that as time progressed and when matt's
movie came out when one is a woman came
out i realized um i thought this was an
opportunity to kind of fix
the
that problem of having you know not run
that interview so i did both at once i
reviewed matt's movie and ran that
interview at the same time and the the
response was unbelievable just for
reviewing the movie forget about what i
said about it um
you know i lost friends over that there
were there were people who who i've
known for decades who who have now
basically said that i'm a transphobe and
i i
i'm kind of out of their loop now
simply for review for acknowledging
the existence of the film he loses
friends for that so it's actually
it actually takes it shouldn't but it
takes real courage simply to
to acknowledge the existence of a film
that the trans activists don't like
takes actual courage um especially if
you live kind of in the world that
mataibi lives in
um
where you've got friends whether you're
gonna actually sacrifice
friends because of it
uh and and also his um
his write-up of the film
it was thoughtful it was interesting
um he praises some aspects i mean he
does criticize other aspects of the film
i don't agree with his criticisms
obviously but he does criticize it so
it's not like a
i wouldn't call it a glowing review
necessarily he just kind of talks about
it he writes about it and and gives his
take on it and and all that that's
that's like that's what you're supposed
to do or especially if you're a film
critic that's what you're supposed to do
but i just went to rotten tomatoes just
to chicks i hadn't checked in a while
and so we're up to
over 5 000 audience ratings
with a 97 score
which i can tell you
i'm a little biased but that's
impressive
to have that high of a score
and still
now we're now it's four critic reviews
is what is what was what there are as
opposed to like most movies we'll have
dozens you know even over like dozens
and dozens of reviews
and um
these are not mainstream critic reviews
one is from christian toto who writes
for the daily wire another's from the
gospel coalition
um and then film threat which is the
closest thing to a mainstream critic
reviewing the film and then a website
called synagogues.com that's it those
are the
film critics who actually reviewed the
film
all the mainstream critics
from the very beginning made it very
clear that we we all agree we're going
to pretend this does not exist
but it does you go to what is warm.com
and see for yourself well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from that wall show if
you did be sure to subscribe to this
youtube channel and click the
notification button to get more content
like this if you want to watch or listen
to the full show head to dailywire.com
and subscribe today you can also listen
to my podcast on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcasts